[Music]
when you're a kid
[Music]
keep that to always be protected cared
for we like hanging with you thanks
shouldn't think it's too much hang out
with us makes you a loser too
but when you're alone as a kid
[Music]
the master she was weaker
[Applause]
you don't even know they're getting
closer until it's too late what we're
supposed Eddie no we're okay well I'm
sorry it cheap and I'm pretty sure this
is not the same bathroom as your mother
sometimes yeah
then you probably have crabs it's so not
funny Martinez coming in ah it's gray
water what the hell is gray water
it's basically piss and [ __ ] so I'm just
telling you you guys are splashed around
and millions of gallons of dairy pee so
what are you serious wait doesn't smell
like a cop donation you have your kind
of a staph infection also so unsanitary
you're literally this is Laura coming
inside of a toilet bowl right now you're
the reason why we're in this position my
gosh who's sneaker is it
it's Betty rips oops what if she's still
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go she's already captain
Thanks
[Music]
Jerry's not like any time I've ever been
in before people tire disappear six
times the national average
unless you're screams kids are worse I
saw something there is this
look it's all connected by sewers
that's for it lives
[Music]
oh if you'll come with me don't float
too long down
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]